من الغرب لاوكرانيا لتكبيد روسيا
الخسائر لكن الخسارة الحقيقية
فعله بهذه التحركات. الاحداث
والتطورات. نجحت كوريا الجنوبية
البحرية التركية وذلك كجزء من
مشروع تسليم سبع وعشرين مدرعة
ابحاث صينية منطقة قريبة من حقول
غاز تعد من ضمن المناطق
احدث تصعيد للتوترات العسكرية
بشأن الجزيرة بينما دخلت سفينة
وامن اراضيها. هناك ابحرت حاملة
طائرات صينية عبر مضيق تايوان في
الخارجية التي اعلنت ان بيع
اسلحة امريكية لتايوان خطوة
خاطئة وخطيرة للغاية. وان الصين
سوف تحمي بشدة سيادتها الوطنية
بعد اشتباكات استمرت عدة ساعات
بين الطرفين. استخدمت فيها
ستحمي دول البلطيق في حال وقوع
هجوم عسكري عليها. وكانت وزارة
برمائية الى القوات البحرية
التركية. اغلقت السلطات
قادمة من الولايات المتحدة.
لياتي الرد الصيني من وزارة
اخر. لكن في دول البلطيق هذه
المرة. حيث صرح المستشار
الاسلحة الخفيفة والثقيلة بحسب
وكالة مور اند خمسون مليار دولار
الروسي يا سادة. فيما اعلنت
وزارة الدفاع الاوكرانية ان كندا
تمد يديها نحو الغرب وهذه طلبت
كييب من برلين رسميا تزويدها
بصواريخ كروز بعيدة المدى من
طراز تاوروس قادرة على ضرب
اداب الاوكران. فكيف سيرد الدب
الروسي? التحرشات الغربية بروسيا
عشر شخصا وتم حظر التصدير الى
ثمانين شركة. ليعلن وزير
الخارجية الروسي سيرجي لافروف
خلال استقباله الموفد الصيني
مشيدا بالدور لبكين. ومن انعدام
الحل السلمي الى الحلول
الاوكراني دانييل جيتمانتسيف
يعلن ان كييف تلقت اكثر من خمسين
وهذه المرة اشعلت طوكيو فتيل
التوترات مجددا. وذلك بعودتها
ذلك بانه طلب خطير وحساس ينذر
بحرب عالمي. وعند التدقيق قليلا.
اليابان فوضعت نفسها مجددا على
قائمة الدول غير الصديقة لموسكو.
اشترتها الولايات المتحدة من
الكيان الاسرائيلي. وتعد هذه
المروحيات سلاحا خطيرا قد يظهر
اوكرانيا قريبا بانتظار الرد
تستكمل خلال الاسابيع المقبلة
تسليم الاف من قطع الاسلحة
الصغيرة والذخيرة الحية التي
تبرعت بها لاوكرانيا. اما
طراز هايمورس وهارم امريكية
الصنع واسقطت ايضا تسع عشرة
لا تنتهي حيث نقلت مصادر
اسرائيلية ان الامريكان قد يسلم
فعن اي مبالغ فلكية نتحدث ومع كل
تلك الخسائر لا تزال اوكرانيا
موسكو. وذلك وفق صحيفة فرانكفورت
العامة الالمانية ليعتبر الروس
فصواريخ تاروس بعيدة المدى ويمكن
تثبيتها على مقاتلات اف ستة عشر
التي تنتظر اوكرانيا استلامها من
لتصبح الاراضي الروسية في مرمى
تركية تدخل سوق العمالقة وكوريا
الجنوبية تضع الملح في جراح كيما
الطلب وهل تستجيب برلين؟ اليابان
تشعل فتيل التوتر مع الدب الروسي
مجددا. واحفاد هتلر يتحركون
عسكريا فاين هي الوجهة؟ امريكا
مليار دولار كدعم خارجي منذ بدء
العملية العسكرية الروسية الخاصة
يبدو انها ليست سوى مليارات
الغرب التي ذهبت ولن تعود.
سلاح امريكي مرعب يورط الكيان
الاسرائيلي في الحرب الاوكرانية.
عرفنا متى بدأت لكن لا احد متى
تنتهي؟ وبعد اكثر من خمسة عشر
اوكرانيا عشرين مروحية ضاربة من
طراز افاتشي ايه اتش سيكس
التي تتصدر المشهد الغربي والسبب
حرب اوكرانيا. هذه الحرب التي
النووية. وساعة الصفر بين ايران
وافغانستان تدق ناقوسها والنتائج
شهرا من الحرب ها هو رئيس لجنة
المالية والضرائب في البرلمان
الى خط حيث قالت وزارة الخارجية
اليابانية ان الحكومة تبنت حزمة
وكيف توجه طلبا خطيرا للالمان
ينذر بحرب عالمية. فما هو هذا
حال بكين وواشنطن يا اصدقاء. حيث
صرح ثعلب السياسة الامريكية وزير
لديهما يمكن ان يهدد ذلك بتدمير
الحضارة بحسب بولستري جورنال.
بين الولايات المتحدة والصين
يقترب من ان يتحولا الى صراع
بمسيرة منغمتين استهدف محطة
لتكرير النفط في المقاطعة. وقالت
لا تزال مستمرة وتكتسب زخما على
زعمه. لننتقل بكم نحو تحرك عسكري
الاقتصادية التابعة لفيتنام. فما
الذي ينوي اصحاب العيون الضيقة
مدار الارض. اعلن رئيس وكالة
الصناعة الدفاعية اسماعيل ديمير
طائرة مسيرة وقامت بتصفية نحو
خمسمائة مسلح كافة المحاور خلال
الدفاع الالمانية اعلنت انها
ستحرك انظمة الدفاع الجوية
باتريوت من سلوفباكا الى لتوانيا
ضمن الجهود لتوفير الامن لقمة
الخارجية الاسبق هنري كاسنجر في
عيد ميلاده المائة بان التوترات
لكن امريكا لا تلتفت لتصريحات
كيسنجر. حيث اكدت سلطات الدفاع
التايوانية وصول الشحنة الاولى
لصواريخ ستينجر من طراز الى
حقيقي بين الطرفين مضيفا انه
بالنظر الى الاسلحة الحالية
عن تسليم مدرعات برمائية محلية
الصنع من طراز زاهر القوات
في اطلاق صاروخ نور الفضائي الذي
اوصل ثمانية اقمار صناعية الى
الافغانية معبر جسر الحرير
الحدودي في ولاية نمروز مع ايران
عقوبات جديدة ضد روسيا شملت هذه
المرة ثمان وسبعين مؤسسة وسبعة
كروز بعيدي المدى من طراز ستوم
شارون كانت بريطانيا قدمتهما
الاوكران تشتيت قوات موسكو وذلك
بسحب الحرب الى العمق الروسي.
لهوي في موسكو انه يرى عقبات
جدية امام حل سلمي في اوكرانيا.
لاوكرانيا. واعلنت الدفاع
الروسية انها تصدت لصواريخ من
العسكرية. هنا قالت موسكو ان
دفاعاتها الجوية اعترضت صاروخي
وهنا قالت وزارة الدفاع الروسية
ان قواتها احبطت محاولة مجموعة
تخريبية اوكرانية لاختراق خط
الجبهة في اتجاه مدينة الكسندر
عن سيطرة الكرملين وذلك لان ما
سماها الانتفاضة في اراضي بلجرود
الناتو التي ستستضيفها الدولة
الواقعة في منطقة البلطيق في شهر
الساعات الماضية. ومن اوكرانيا
الى الاراضي الروسية حيث يحاول
يوليو. صراع القوى العظمى. الحرب
الباردة لن تدوم طويلا. فاما ان
مصادر روسية ان قصفا مدفعي
اوكرانيا استهدف منطقة بلجرود
تشتعل حرب حقيقية او ان الاطراف
ستفضل التهدئة والصلح وهذا هو
الروسية. ليعلنها المسؤول في
جهاز المخابرات الاوكرانية
اندريوسوب. بان بعض البلدات
منطقة بلجرود الروسية باتت خارجة
كالينوفسكي. بينما اعلن حاكم
مقاطعة بيسكوب الروسية ان هجوما
الالماني خلال زيارته العاصمة
الاستونية تالين ان المانيا
كارثية. خمسون مليار دولار في
مهب الريح. الخسائر ولا غيرها هي
تضع يدها في خاصرة الصين وبكين
تتوعد بالرد بقوة. ولاول مرة